you can see her now in lessons in
chemistry on Apple TV plus and in the
Marvels which is in theaters right now I
love all the things you do what I found
crazy though is that you're singing and
dancing in the new Marvels yeah we can
talk about that now finally I know like
were you excited about that I was
thrilled I the whole time when I first
read the script I was like they're not
going to let me actually do this but
they did they did and it was a lot of
work we had to rehearse for like a month
um James Murphy of LCD sound system did
the music and it was incredible
absolutely incredible and it's so it's
like CU it's one of the places that you
go and they all sing yes it's a planet
where their language is in song so
that's they don't know they can't hear
anything unless this my Planet it's yeah
it's really fun I would love this planet
you actually released an album as a teen
which I did not know and found out
that's probably for the best well you
saw from Justin M Kelly so that's
probably not the best but we all have
our things but no but what what kind of
style was it it was I mean it was Pop I
played guitar I wrote the songs um you
like writing though you enjoy
[Applause]
wowers finally out of PE yeah that's not
they see and these are reasons why
15-year-olds shouldn't have albums you
know or why they should do that or yeah
or maybe they should I even look back at
my stuff and I'm like I always say I
should make an album like better with
age and like recut things cuz you're
just babies right and your voice isn't
like gr you know you whatever you don't
know what you're doing or I didn't know
what I was I should say that but it was
I mean it was really fun it was just
strange thing that happened I still
can't believe that that happened a lot
of actors sing though like a lot of
actors that come on the show I didn't
really know that before doing the show
but a lot of people are like in bands or
we're in bands and they always like I
don't do anymore I'm like whatever I was
like you love you I think it's awesome
to be creative like that totally you
should sing with me when tell on the
show just say
[Music]
okay
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home